say again thank you very much for coming
tonight we're very excited to have David
Thibodeau here he's going to be speaking
and then we'll take some of your
questions for about half an hour please
help me welcome David Thibodeau I'm used
to standing when I do these things but
this this would be a different form Wow
thank you so much all for coming out
it's a pleasure to be here tonight in
the live music capital of the world
Austin Texas and I'm very proud to be in
Austinite now and it's different when
you do I've done these up for last
couple weeks
then quite a few signings and it's just
it's just different when you see your
your your crowd here from from the place
that you live so thank you for coming
out I guess I'll start off at the
beginning to try to keep it brief
sometimes I tend to get a little
sidetrack because in this issue there's
so much to cover and one of the problems
I guess I'll start with one of the
problems with with with the with the
trials that occurred in San Antonio six
and a half years ago up to the Senator
Danforth in inquest it's gonna be
occurring on coming up in the next
couple months is the trials in San
Antonio focused on the events of
February 28th than the be ATF attack and
basically they tried the people 11 of
them on conspiracy to commit murder
charges which everyone was acquitted of
that charge several of them were found
guilty of a lesser charge of aiding and
abetting voluntary manslaughter but due
to a little snafu well the the jury was
given a ninety four page rulebook that
they had to follow in the trials I see a
lot of people shaking their head I mean
a jury should be able to hear all the
evidence that's the way I view it and
they shouldn't be limited by a federal
judge saying this is what you have to do
when you make your decision so they were
basically five of them were found guilty
of having of well nine of them were
found guilty of having a firearm during
what the judge called the commission of
a crime for February 28 and that is when
the btf attacked if you had a gun in
your hand basically you went to jail
some of them are in jail for 40 years on
a weapons violation that the jury felt
was thrown out according to the count
three aspect of the verdict so I have
talked to Sarah Bain the head jury
forewoman
that was there that day at the trials in
San Antonio and she said had we seen all
the evidence that we had seen since the
trials that the judge suppressed from us
we would have acquitted everybody on all
charges so basically right now there's
seven political prisoners some of which
have been under very harsh conditions
and in various institutions throughout
the country some of them are there for
40 years on a weapons violation that the
jury was thrown out and I think that's a
very important point to make the whole
problems of the trials in San Antonio
was the fact that the judge focused only
on February 28th and my concern is with
the hearings of Danforth he's only gonna
focus on the events of April 19th and
what happened at the back of the
building and of course the infrared
videotape that we'll be discussing a
little later so the big problem that I
have is you can't really understand Waco
you can't understand what really
happened there unless you handle it from
A to Z and you cover everything in
between because what the FBI did when
they set up their speaker systems it was
so crass the light systems literally the
psychological effect of here's the guy
that they say David Koresh is a persons
very unstable and you have a bunch of
religious wackos is what we've been
called consistently throughout the
course of the 51 days and their plan is
to play loud music sounds of rabbits
being slaughtered
Tibetans monk chant and chanting just
various taking the phone off the hook
for 48 hours at a time so their plan was
to make us even more unstable that
doesn't make a lot of sense to me
so the point I wanted to make in opening
up is I hope senator Danforth the former
senator Danforth and I hope that some of
the the civil cases and the Senate
inquest it's going to be taking place
will focus more than just on April 19th
cuz you'll never be able to see the big
picture unless you focus on the whole
thing from A to Z so with that I'd like
to start off by saying I'm David
Thibodeau and I grew up in Bangor Maine
and ever since I was a little kid and I
first picked up drumsticks I knew what I
wanted to do with my life I wanted to
play music and so I did everything in my
power to make that dream happen once
they graduated from high school I got a
job I started saving up to go to Los
Angeles I played in several bands came
home from school every single day and
played the drums had just lived in that
little world literally closing my eyes
and seeing thousands of people in front
of me and just getting off on the rush
of what that would be like every day and
that was my only goal in life setting
out and this whole adventure and I ended
up in Hollywood finally and I graduated
from music school and over the course of
the next six months or so I was playing
in a band out there and I was at a
dead-end job I was working at Mann's
Chinese Theater at the gift shop
and I had one of those stupid red socks
on and I remember one day I was so
frustrated with my life I I looked up to
the heavens or at least I looked up to
the ceiling of man Chinese Theater and I
said Lord what are you saving me for you
know when can I finally meet the people
and I'm supposed to meet so I can start
my life so I can do what I want to do
instead of being in this rut and I said
you know just please make this happen I
know that I'm here for a reason I know
that I'm not here just aimlessly walking
through life in Hollywood living you
know living with a bunch of guys in a
one-room apartment and two days later I
was late for a band rehearsal I had my
band members with me and I made them
literally made them they didn't want to
do it I made them stop and at a Guitar
Center on Sunset Boulevard so I could
buy some drumsticks and when I did I
walked into the electronic drum room
which I had had a very bad habit of
doing he always had a kid setup and I
would always sit down and play it and
there were these two gentlemen that were
standing there looking at the electronic
drum set and they asked me if I was a
drummer so I was and I sat down I played
the drums for him they said that they
would be interested in purchasing this
kit and they wanted to hear it so I sat
down and played for three minutes or so
and when I got up the guy a there was a
guy in a business suit and there was a
guy in a t-shirt with ragged jeans it
was just kind of really laid-back and
the guy the suit if you will approach me
and he says why you know pretty good
drummer we're
we're looking for one for our band or
would you be interested in getting
together with us I said yeah sure and
I'm in a band now but I'm always
interested to play with different people
and so they handed me their card and I
looked at the card on the back of the
card there was all this religious
scripture I was revolving around the
kingdom to be set up I didn't realize
that at the time nor did I really care
I saw the religious scripture and I
handed the card back to him I said well
thank you very much you know I'm the
spiritual person but I don't believe
that I'm really looking to being a
Christian man at this time and that's
when Steve piped up and he said well you
know it's like this we're not really a
Christian band what we are as we've
studied the scripture I've been all over
the world with this guy David Koresh and
he introduced David and David didn't
really say too much he just kind of sat
back and let's Steve do most of the
talking he said I've been all over the
world and you know I've we've studied
this this this book they call the Bible
we've ripped it apart and we just have
some insights to it and you know really
all we want to do is play music right
now and you know we do have a message
that is revolving around the scripture
but you know that's really not our focus
right now we just would like to play
music with you and say ok I kind of left
with the attitude don't call me I'll
call you and a couple days later you
know things were going so low and I just
started thinking about this and I was
really impressed with the suit and he
was a very good oratory and a Steve
Schneider and and and David is just real
quiet and you know kind of mysterious he
said a few things and then I gave him a
call and over the course of the next day
or so we got together and went they had
a property in Pomona about 45 minutes
out of Hollywood and we went there and
played some music I thought David was a
great guitarist I met their artist cliff
sellers who had paint airbrush two
guitars and it was just they seemed to
really have it together they were very
professional and that's something that I
liked over the course the next couple
months I got to know him a little better
and specifically Steve Schneider would
come over with some of the guys and give
us studies because I said you know we
want to show you some of these things
out of this book and I remember the
first night I had my roommates and they
were all sitting around I said hey I
forgot to tell you guys but I have a
couple people coming over for we're
gonna have a Bible study I hope you
don't mind
and they were like why didn't you tell
us you know I could have gotten a date
with my girlfriend or we could have gone
out to the movies or something you know
and they were literally reaching for
their coats when the knock came at the
door and it was Steve Schneider and it's
Jamie Castillo Greg summers just several
of the younger guys were there
I even think cliff was there as he Peter
was there Peter hips man and you should
have seen the look on their faces when
the door nod and I opened the door and
they all came in and said hey you know
you're already they had they had a
12-pack of beer with them you know all
of a sudden my roommate said well you
know I think we can stay for a few
minutes and then what they got to say
and I just remember when Steve Schneider
sat down and he had this one-inch margin
Bible you know we can make your notes
and he opened that book and every page
that he had had all this spirit had all
this cross references color coded in it
on every single page it was just
absolutely filled with cross references
instantly I was impressed cuz I could
see that these I was never impressed and
I hope I don't offend anyone here but I
was never oppressed with the TV
preachers and the hypocrisy of not all
but several organized religions you know
I was always more into the small
movements of religion that seemed to be
a little more pure in heart and as they
grow and of course it becomes a money
financial institution it tends to lose
focus a little I think a lot and so I
was impressed with the way that they rip
the Bible apart and they had really done
their research and studied and and
that's what impressed me was the fact
that it was more of an intellectual
study than it was an indoctrination or
they never came off preachy that would
have turned me off instantly and so they
went through their study and two hours
late I'm looking around my roommates are
still sitting there I to me that was an
act of God and I remember the course of
the next couple months we got together
several occasions and had studies then
one day David crèche invited me out to
Waco Texas a place called Waco and he
said to be we're going out there for
Passover which is one of the two-week
periods the festival periods of God in
the scripture and he said literally
there's gonna be hundreds of people from
all over the world that are going to be
coming to learn these true
he says you're gonna meet you know
people that are carpenters people that
are architects people that have gone to
seminary school people that are pastors
in their own churches in England I said
well that sounds kind of interesting and
he asked me if I wanted to go and at the
time I was pretty adventurous him and I
did so we pulled up to Mount Carmel and
I took a look at all the the single
buildings that line the place up and I
just thought it was one of the strangest
places I'd ever seen in my life
and we got there a week early so we
started playing some music and stuff and
people started arriving and I started to
question these people I said me why are
you here what do you hope to gain from
this and I must have talked to 10 or 15
different people at various times and
they basically all told me the same
thing they said that they had learned
more about the scripture from this
person David Koresh and they had their
whole life studying on their own or
being pastors are going to seminary
school and it's just like everyone
seemed to have the same testimony and so
I wanted to see what it was gonna be you
know what it was really all about I
always knew that there was a mystery to
this book I always wondered in my life
how come so many thousands and thousands
of people have died put their lives on
the line and sacrifice their lives for
this scripture throughout the course of
time it has a power to it and over the
course of that - we sent member the very
first study and and the reason that I'm
relating the stories cuz a lot of people
asked me you know how could you follow
someone like David Koresh people say
this but they have no idea who he was
all they know is what they've heard and
they've made their judgments because
I've heard some very bad things well
there's always two sides of the story in
this case there's I think hundreds of
sides to the story
the first study that he gave II we hit a
bot he had a Bible and he held it up he
says most people see this book and they
see two pieces of cow leather and a
bunch of pages in between and they spend
their life trying to unravel the mystery
or get some kind of basic truth out of
it he says no when I see and he held up
to his forehead he goes when I see it I
see it panoramic Li as if it's happening
now from Genesis to Revelation right now
as it's happening you know that was
pretty tough pill to
but over the course of the next two
weeks we had studies that would last
anywhere from 10 to 12 hours a day and
they were they were a very entertaining
I mean it wasn't something that I found
dry I mean I actually started to become
involved and become part of this world
of the scripture and it was something
that I started to embrace and I
literally over the course that two weeks
came to believe and you know and I
wasn't even 100% sure if this was the
final message or this was the messenger
but I came to believe that David did see
the scripture that way
panorama CLE is if it had happened as if
he had been there and when he gave a
study he gave a study with literally the
looks on the faces of the people that
are written in the scripture so you
could actually see the sarcasms you
could see the nuances of the
communication that was taking place in
the Bible where before I could never see
that reading and on my own it just made
me go to sleep frankly and so it was
something that held the interest I think
one thing that I saw David do on several
occasions and he did this with me as
well after that two or three-week period
when everyone started to leave and
played music a little more and you know
I was trying to absorb all the stuff he
says what I wanted to do now is you know
I I want you to be my drummer I want you
to be in the band but you've have now
have the the basic foundations of the
seven seals first five seals if you will
and what I want to do is see would you
like to go to Maine and see your parents
absolutely I'd love to go see my parents
you know it was on him right why not
and my head was spinning frankly I
definitely needed some time to absorb it
all and so he sent me up to Maine he
said you know take a couple weeks take a
month take whatever time you need if you
find that you know and ask people about
these seven seals go to preachers go to
rabbis go to anybody and if they have
some insight in the seals let me know I
might be interested in but if I'm pretty
sure you're gonna find that no one even
knows what they are or the most people
gonna say that there's a mystery and
waiting for Christ to come back before
those things can be revealed if they
don't know when you want to learn more
come on back you know we want to have
you in and I said well okay that's
pretty fair well over the course of the
next month I'm I went to Maine and I got
a call one day about a month later and I
was putting it off because I I was
convicted at this point I mean I had
known that there were
something there but at the same time I
didn't really want to entirely give up
my life and just go and live on what we
call the anthill because we got the
Texas fire ants here and there's several
at Mount Carmel so I ended up going back
and I ended up going back to Hollywood
and several events took place if you
will I'm gonna kind of wrap it up real
quickly here within six months we ended
up of being in Hollywood we ended up
moving to Mount Carmel
there's several events that took that
took place that are really important but
because I really want to get to
questions you're gonna have to look it
up in the book but a lot of very very
interesting very deep things happen to
me during that period of time that I was
in Hollywood and a lot of them revolved
around a certain friend of mine who's
who was in a band as well out there and
Koresh had some insights that literally
just just just blew me away that he
could know this about my friend and all
these things were factors so we ended up
moving to Mount Carmel about a year
before the be ATF attack February 28th
and throughout that year we tore down
the little houses and we started to
build up them the major complex they're
called Mount Carmel and the big building
that everyone saw we built a swimming
pool David Koresh and Steve Schneider
would Steve wouldn't he was you know a
brilliant salesman I mean Steve
basically would negotiate all the deals
we ended up getting go-karts building a
track the children some of the younger
boys got small dirt bikes and would we
would all go out and play on the track
what ended up happening is through a
person that I met in Waco and we had
ties in Waco I mean this wasn't some
community that was just totally within
themselves out in the middle of nowhere
I mean the Branch Davidians are what
became to be known as the Branch
Davidians actually the Branch Davidians
stemmed from an earlier group that had
lived out there had been there for 60
years
David Koresh was the third of what
people out there called inspired or if
you will a prophet and he was the third
one to get the complete vision of the
seven seals before them there was hot
off' and louis rodent
who preceded David so it wasn't just
some fly-by-night group that David
started it was something that built off
a foundation of several years and there
were several people that had been there
almost from the inception of it who tell
me stories them David first came on the
scene his name was Vernon Howell when he
first came on the scene he was basically
he could barely formulate a sentence I
mean he had a great knowledge of the
scripture but he was no order he was
great with working on cars but he
stuttered he had a stuttering problem
and literally after 1985 when he claimed
to have his vision of the seven seals he
started to talk very clearly very
concisely and it was almost like an
overnight transformation that a lot of
the older people there told me about
which I thought was very impressed
impressive
why I ended up meaning someone whose
father was Henry McMahon who was a
licensed firearm dealer that ran a place
called a Hewitt handguns and was right
outside of Waco in Hewitt Texas and
Henry basically started get studies from
David and started to learn a lot of
things and thought that you know David
was someone that was very special
someone was very inspired and started to
take David to gun shows I mean that was
kind of his forte and through these
little excursions of going to gun shows
here in Texas the David and Paul and
Stephen Schneider found out a couple
things they found out that because of
all them the legislation is coming down
the pike of two to three rounds is going
up in value that ak-47s are going up in
value from $500 to $2,000 overnight and
he started to they started to actually
take on the business of going to the gun
shows and doing everything legally and
having the yellow sheets on all the
firearms and basically buying and
selling legally there were people inside
that made vests hunters vests that were
sold that the gun shows as well as
several other things that occurred and
one of the things that ended up
happening is as we were building the
pool that summer the helicopter started
to fly by really low and you know could
tell they were taking pictures we knew
that you know we were being watched I
mean you know a big group of people out
there in the middle of nowheres pretty
strange according to most people
which most Americans tend to forget that
America was founded on a bunch of
religious extremists that came to this
nation and and started to put together
the Constitution and I think it's
important to remember that the bath the
Baptist's were scourging the streets
when they first came and I'm sure a lot
of you know about the history of the
Mormons and what they had to suffer when
they were first starting with with their
particular doctrine and so I comes from
a long foundation of I guess killing or
beating up what you can't understand
what you don't want to understand her
specifically what the establishment can
understand and from this point that
Henry came into being that's when all
the gun stuff started happening a couple
other interesting things took place
well Henry McMahon one day gave us a
call and he had been rated by the be ATF
the Bureau of Alcohol Tobacco and
Firearms and they were going through all
his yellow sheets and they started to
ask Henry and Davy Aguilera the B ATF
agent headed up the whole investigation
you started to ask a lot of questions
about David Koresh to Henry nice as well
Henry says you're investigating me why
you asking me all these questions about
crush you should investigate crash or go
speak with him so Henry excused himself
and went to the kitchen and and this all
came out the trials in San Antonio and
everything I'm saying I can prove it has
happened so David Henry McMahon went
into the other room he got the phone and
he called David and he said David the be
ATF are here and they're raiding me
they're going through all my yellow
sheets and asking me a lot of questions
about you what do you want me to do and
Crush said well why don't you have them
come on out to the property this is
about two to three months before
February 28th I'm come out to the
property they can check out any of the
yellow sheets on any of the firearms
that we purchased they have any
questions better yet put him on the
phone I'll speak to him Henry McMahon
went in the other room and he said I
have David crush on the phone he wants
to speak to you soon by the yard to the
property and Davey Aguilera shook his
head and waved his hands above his head
like this
he didn't want to speak to David never
wanted to ever try to make any contact
with David other than when the when the
four individuals
ended up moving across the street which
was gonna bring me my next story these
four guys move across the street one day
out of the blue this is about a month or
so before the the initial attack and
when they did this there was um you know
four guys move in a two room house they
bring in all this heavy equipment you
know they don't move in furniture but
they move in this equipment and they
start to set up their little
surveillance over the course of the next
couple days well there was an event that
took place I think's pretty funny
Greg summers at the request of the David
brought over some beer and some pizza
the guys across the street to kind of
welcome welcome welcome them to the
neighborhood seems how there's only two
people in the neighborhood you know why
not make friends with their neighbors as
for they knocked at the door and they
said yeah we're from across the street
we just want to bring you guys over some
beer and some pizzas and say hi and his
hand came out the door grab the pizza
pulled the pizza and slam the door and
said thank you I got my girl in here so
that's pretty strange you know I mean
obviously either he had his girl in
there there definitely wasn't something
they did not want us to see so over the
over the course the next week or so they
did come in and finally make contact in
a guy named Robert Rodriguez or Robert
Gonzalez the one's an alias ones his
real name I think Rodriguez was the name
of was the alias came over started to
make contact with David and basically
over the course of the next he had nine
to 13 contacts with David I believe it
was nine and David instantly started
giving him studies know Robert was a man
that was raised Catholic and as David
would give him studies I could see this
look on his face I mean it was like he
was he was starting to get his question
answers like myself and all the people
that were there literally David can
answer all our questions from a
scriptural standpoint now Steve
Schneider and Wayne Martin and Paul FATA
they tried to rip him apart for months
before they joined this community and
they couldn't do it there was an
interview that this that this individual
did with the Washington Times I believe
it was right after the raid after the
well April 19 from the place burned to
the ground and he said a couple of very
interesting things one was
that the interviewer said was David
close meaning were you close to being in
the community are being converted if you
will
he said yeah it was close I think that's
very interesting he said in in other
statements that the agents had to shake
him up and say you're here to do a job
you know you're not here to get
converted Robert come on he also said
that when the FBI took over the FBI said
what can you tell us about David what's
gonna happen next and Robert said well
give me a Bible I'll show you exactly
what he's gonna do next from that
scripture and the FBI looked at him like
he was crazy they wanted nothing to do
with it and then Robert said he went out
through his Bible Elaine and you know it
was very sorrowful you lost four friends
that day and I think it's really
interesting that the be ATF I mean
Robert said he saw no signs of illegal
activity during the time he was in there
and they still went forward with the
raid I mean they have an undercover a
guy in there why won't they work with
their own undercover agent why won't
they listen to what he's saying we'll
talk about the war in a minute but after
this period of time the Waco Tribune
Herald put out what they called this
seven part series of sinful Messiah
series that was very demonizing him is
just a very harsh piece they didn't ask
for our side of the story at all and
they started to talk about if you if
you're Branch Davidian you believe
Christ lives on a thread barren piece of
land in the middle of Waco Texas and
he's a beer-drinking guitar chote and
gun-toting preacher that's how it
started that's like the headline right
and it's the first of a seven part
series because you so you can imagine
that we pretty much saw that something
was about to take place now the problem
I have several problems with the first
of many problems that I have with a be
ATF attack is number one when you look
at the warrant and rip it apart
basically they went to the judge judge
green under false pretenses they relied
on information that was the child abuse
information and allegations came from a
guy named Mark Breaux who's studied
under David for several years and then
left they relied on information that was
five years old under federal law when
you go to a judge you have to have
current information at least six months
old
or at the most six months old before you
can get a warrant against someone Davi a
glare who headed up that report said
that Koresh was receiving upper and
lower receivers to put together fully
automatic ak-47s that's the V ATF agent
the problem with this scenario is an
ak-47 is a solid body firearm you can't
get an upper and lower receiver for it
therefore how can you put it together
make a fully automatic weapon that's an
ak-47 now this is in the Warrens this is
what he went to the judge with to get a
NOC search warrant which the judge
signed he gave him a NOC search warrant
I don't know what your interpretation of
a NOC search warrant is but mine is you
go up to the door you knock on the door
and you serve the warrant you go in and
get your evidence okay they chose to
serve a NOC search warrant of what they
called Operation Trojan horse and the
code word for operation Trojan horse to
go down with Showtime literally It's
Showtime
now they chose to serve this warrant
with two cattle trailers pulling to the
front of the building
four or five ATF teams one team was to
go to the back of the building another
team was to go up to the side of the
building and go into what they thought
was the gun room or the evidence room
and everyone's seen the pictures of that
ATF agent trying to break the window and
get into that door jump into the door
and and then they see all this fire
coming at the ATF agents and you see the
guy go down the ladder
another group of ATF agents was to go to
the front door and quote-unquote serve
the warrant then no one ever saw in
their hand and was sealed up when they
when the FBI had asked for that warrant
they said oh it was all shot up in the
raid so we can't produce that warrant
literally that was sealed up until after
April 19th no one ever saw that search
warrant another group of ATF agents was
to go to the front of an area where we
had a penned up area with with five
Alaskan Malamutes fawn and her four pups
and their job was to suppress the dogs
now there was an ATF and I'm gonna call
it exactly what it is there was an ATF
propaganda film that was put out it was
played on HBO I saw it on Court TV of
all things the other day I mean on court
he have absolutely disgusted I'm sitting
ready to go on hardball and there is
this this this movie is called in the
line of duty and
the reason I bring this up is because
Phil pen and Groff the man that wrote
that was given all this false
information put this movie out it was
made during the siege before April 19th
this was already in production and was
basically completed he has since come
forward and said since he's seen all
this information that the government
didn't get him when he was making this
particular film and call it that he has
said that that it's wrong he he did a
five-page letter and came to one of our
memorials and apologized to all of the
survivors profusely and in his five page
letter he likened himself to I hope I
gets his name right
Lenny Ruth instal who was the woman who
did all the Hitler documentaries and
whence once Lenny went into Poland and
saw what Hitler was really doing and
what the Nazis were all about she pulled
out and all of a sudden became really
really quiet well this guy with much
shame likens himself to her this he made
a propaganda film and the reason I bring
this whole little story up is because in
their film the f the ATF agents go up to
the pendant area where the dogs are with
fire extinguishers and they start
spraying the dogs let me tell you they
didn't have fire extinguishers that day
they shot those dogs in cold blood
from the time from the trial testimony
some of the testimony indicated that the
very first shots may have been fired at
the dogs and the penned up area from the
ATF agents this is all happening
simultaneously while there's three
helicopters in the back of the building
that are supposed to be there for
support coming into the back of the
building shooting at the building
according to several eyewitness
testimony I personally saw the evidence
of the bullet holes that came from had
to come from the sky they were in the
ceiling with literally sheetrock hanging
down I saw they shot up our water tanks
I literally got on my knees and I looked
through the the entry and the exit
wanted the bullet came from right where
the side right where the tank is a
conclave and you could see the bullet
hole where it came in a where it came
out and at an angle you could see was
fired between the two towers that we had
out there I was fired from the air
absolutely that's the one that killed
Winston Blake
so my point they choose they chose to
serve this warrant like in like a
dynamic entry style or a no-knock search
warrant I mean they're already breaking
down windows while they're coming up to
serve the warrant now the ATF is claimed
profusely that it was an ambush that
they were outgunned well if we were a
group of if you will quote-unquote
cultists that wanted to kill the
Babylonians or kill federal authorities
and we had fully automatic weapons and
we had 50 caliber machine guns and we
were had had 45 minutes where we knew
that they were coming and we were laying
wait for meeeeee I'm here to tell you
unless we're terrible terrible shots and
all blind not one of those agents would
have walked off that cattle trailer it
was simply never part of the plan there
was no plan the agents had died the four
agents that died died 20 minutes into
the gun battle we have videotape of
these agents standing behind cars
standing up shooting into the second
storey of the building where all the
kids are like it's a set of a Rambo
movie and yet they've been ambushed they
were outgunned their story from day one
never made any sense two pieces of
evidence I'm gonna bring up really
quickly one is the front door and at
that front door it was very mysterious
because the story from my friends on the
inside was a David crush went to the
door yeah I had he came down thirty
seconds before the shooting began he
said now they're on their way they're
coming don't anybody do anything stupid
we want to talk to them we want to work
it out that's were all about here he was
the front door and just literally all
hell broke loose I instantly was down on
my face I spoke to several people that
are at the front door they all told me
the same story at various times that
crash went to the door he held the door
in his hand he had his arm out he said
hold on there's women chilling here
let's talk about this the door flies
back in his hand from a velocity of a
bullet hitting it he slams the door and
falls back parry-jones a seven-year-old
on our man goes down and pain from a
stomach wound and from that point some
of the people inside started to fire
back and defend their positions so this
door was very important because we have
pictures of it and the two attorneys I
should say David Koresh's attorney
and and Steve Snyder's attorney actually
came in via the tanks one day actually
on two or three separate occasions and
saw the evidence of the helicopters
firing they saw the front door and they
saw that all the bullet holes are coming
from the outside into the building now
there were two steel doors at the front
of the building one of them was entered
in or metal doors I don't know if they
were steel there were metal one was
entered into the evidence list the
trials of San Antonio and the other
wasn't it was conspicuously missing and
the defense attorney says what about
these these this metal door where is
this metal door that had all the bullet
holes in it and all the prosecuting
attorneys could say and their defense
was oh that door must have disintegrated
in the fire its sister door is entered
into evidence it's fully intact
it's got a couple you know bumps and
knocks and bends from the tanks running
it over but the other door mysteriously
disintegrates in the fire doesn't make
sense the second little piece of
information that I want you all to know
about is the fact the ATF were recording
us they had cameras at their
surveillance house running all the time
the FBI when they came in and took over
the scene the first thing they said was
we want all all the video tape of the
early stages of the raid that you have
the ATF said we don't have any videotape
of the early stages of the raid I'm
afraid all of our cameras malfunctioned
it becomes very convenient I mean you
know you could say you can say that I'm
just making all this up it's like it's
all a matter of record it's all it the
the trials in San Antonio you know I
have a website we're making an
informational site the name of the book
a place called Waco calm and I have the
reports in the CS guess I want to make
the evidence available I think that we
have been lied to enough for the last
six and a half years we've been lied to
consistently and it's time to lay it on
the table I mean if you will David
Koresh myself you put a lot of our dirty
laundry exposed why can't the government
do the same thing and say well let's you
know I think the American public is can
take it I think we can take the truth
and I don't think it should be
suppressed from us I think that's why we
have a constitutional nation I mean I
was raised very patriotically I remember
reading in the history books at Valley
Forge
you know how our forefathers the people
that died so we can have this kind of
freedoms that we have in this country
and have a constitutional foundation and
all the people that went off to Vietnam
they didn't even know why and died for
us and yet our government can pull this
on I say it's just a terrible thing you
know it's a terrible thing and all I've
ever said since they want is let's let's
lay it all out on the table well as you
can see this is gonna create an
atmosphere of mistrust which of course
it did and over the course of the next
51 days the FBI takes over and you know
we felt that we'd have a better time
with the eight with the FBI then we did
the ATF and a lot of things happen they
set up the speaker systems they started
to use this I cops and they actually
consulted Russian specialists so they
can make sure to get the best psych ops
and I guess they figured we'd be like
was it Noriega when they when they went
into Panama he was he was holding now
and they started to play rock and roll
music well the day they set up the
speaker system the very first thing they
played was an old Alice Cooper album hey
that just delighted me you know and
Jamie and some of the younger guys were
like excellent started calling in for
request you know hey you know the new
Def Leppard gallon came out and we're in
a siege you think he can play that for
us they weren't too happy about that and
that's when they started to change their
tone and they had the Roberts being
slaughtered and the phone off the hook
for from 24 hours 48 hours whatever it
was and you know from that point on
things just got worse and worse and
worse and through the course of the FBI
controlling all the media attention and
basically telling you what to think we
became the craziest bunch of religious
wackos you'd ever seen on the face of
the earth that probably deserve what
they got I mean I think thousands and
thousands of people are coming around
now and they realized they have been
lied to but I think the general American
public still holds that perception I
think that's too bad some of the people
at Mount Carmel I just want to go on
record as saying with the most brilliant
people I've ever known in my life
I mean I'd love to be around people that
are better than me I like to play with
musicians that are better than me
because that's how you grow you know I
like to be around brilliant people and
they were the most brilliant I've ever
known way
Marton the harvard-educated attorney
Steve Schneider taught classes on
comparative religions Livingston Fagan
one of the gentlemen that's in jail
right now who's been in solitary
confinement for years
Livingston Fagan he was a pastor of his
own church in England he came over to
study and I think it's important for
people to know that the third of the
people that lived and died at Mount
Carmel were black or is the ACLU when we
needed him you know I mean Rodney King
we had riots in the streets but no one
knew this no one knew that it was such a
diverse group of people and cultures
that existed a Mount Carmel this time
people knew a third of the people were
black I mean that's you know they can't
make us out to be the racist that they
would have liked to have made us out to
been and some of the reports came out
there was racial issues and tensions
going on which as it was so was not true
no I'll give you an example and this is
one of the things that occurred and this
is why David was so misunderstood and
people like Mark Breaux really fought
against him there's lots of reasons but
he had a study one day and he says I
hate black people and I you know I was
raised pretty liberal I was pretty
shocked and everyone was quiet because I
hate yellow people and I hate white
people because we here are people of
light we are people that want to
understand the truth and that's what I
relate to I want people of light around
me no colors you know no nothing to
limit you and he would always do stuff
like that to provoke you and make you
think and then there was always a wisdom
behind it and that's one of the things
that impressed upon me well I'm gonna
wrap it up to April 19th so we can start
taking questions several things did
occur and I just want people to know I
was reading a lot of material today and
one of the things that I read was by a
gentleman who's whose who is a very
interesting website and he did some
articles and you have to understand that
when you're in a building and they're
starting to play interviews from people
that hate you and want nothing to do
with you and think you're strange and
think you're wacko and think the base
worthy of life you start to realize that
there's no allies out there there's it's
us against the world it's not us against
the at-bats against the world hates us
now more than everything we got in to
talk to us and yet they just soon have
us wiped out I mean we were hearing this
on speaker systems and you start to say
to yourself you know people want to say
the crest was guilty of self fulfilling
his prophecy I think that during the
course of that 51 days the number of
lies that came out that the FBI if there
was a guidebook they could follow of
what not to do in the situation that's
the guidebook they chose to listen to
they didn't listen to their psychologist
that said don't allow Koresh's message
to come to pass pull back don't increase
the tension but alleviate the tension
you know they didn't listen to the human
side of it you there's a picture in Waco
the rules of engagements in where
there's this infrared video but even
before that they have scenes where
they're talking to the negotiators and
we sent them out of tape I mean everyone
during the siege told their story on a
videotape and we sent it out so people
would relay and say you know these are
people here that are religious people
they're studying this book and they have
a right to do that you know no they may
be guilty of crimes but they've just so
demonized that when we sent them this
tape of all the people and I did a
little interview the FBI chose to
suppress that from the public and it
came out in the congressional hearings
the congressional hearings they asked
about this tape and they say the FBI
literally said we felt that if we were
to release this tape to the public it
would create much support and sympathy
for the Branch Davidians Oh what you
mean he might humanize us you know it
might take away from your demonization
you know I mean I give Thaksin people
say mr. Thibodeau you've done a great
job at hiding your horns and your cloven
hoods you know I mean from the
perception I get from the press it's
what I expected
when you came here I said before I move
on I wanted there's a quote that I
thought was very
and it's exactly what has happened it
follows precisely what took place and
Senator Henry Clay said this in the
1800's he said the devices of power and
its minions are the same in all
countries and in all ages it marks its
victim and announces it exciting the
public hatred so it can conceal its own
abuses and encroachments now I read that
I committed it to memory because it
absolutely fit with what happened here
and I'm just going to give you one more
parable if you will before we talk about
April 19th I'm a big fan of George
Orwell's Animal Farm I'm very happy to
see that it is now AT&T moving and I'm
really looking looking very forward to
seeing that but if those of you that are
familiar with this story will know that
the pigs that's pretty interesting
equalization that that the pigs were the
power structures of the farm and the
horses were the workers and everyone had
their role and every time one of the
farm animals questioned the authority of
the pigs the Sheep who weren't too
bright the sheeple would break in to
their mantra four legs good two legs bad
four legs good two legs bad and the
whole farm would break into this manner
and they would forget the question they
would forget to question the pigs and
question authority because the whole
world saying four legs good two legs bad
and the FBI over the course of 51 days
every single day consistently federal
agents good Branch Davidians bad federal
agents good branch davidians bad and the
entire nation joined in you know and I
it's a shame because I feel that we have
the greatest country on the face of the
earth I feel that Americans are
incredibly industrial we've done so much
to advance technology and to advance
this world that we're not smart enough
to say I mean there should have been
someone who said stop that was Janet
Reno's job she said stop
you know these people may be strange you
know but there's two factions here and
there's kids involved which brings me
back to my original point
in Waco the rules of engagement when
they go in and they show the negotiators
you got a picture of of what they called
the compound when I called my home they
got a picture of Mount Carmel and I got
a picture of David Koresh and the whole
mental attitude was that's the criminal
this is the enemy we need to get him
they should have had pictures of
serenity Jones and Joseph and Isaiah and
startled and Cyrus and the and and the
kids that were in that building that
negotiators house and the tactical
commanders houses should have been lined
up with the pictures of these kids and
the attitude should have been this is an
innocent child we need to do whatever it
takes to get them out of there
and if it means speaking crush's
language and not you know caste sizing
him in the media and getting to
theologians in that are willing to work
with us like James Tabor and Phil Arnold
who karesh wanted to get his manuscript
out to then that's what we got to do I
think it's unfortunate than such a
brilliant nation that the ball was
dropped that we lost sight of that the
people are dead now because of it you
know what I'm not gonna talk about April
19th because I want to open up the
questions I know running out of time and
I know that someone's gonna ask me about
it so we'll get into some really juicy
stuff there is that okay yeah
incidentally this is being recorded for
c-span it's gonna go on national so if
you have a good question
stand up and face the camera and make
sure everyone can hear you yes sir you
just made about the the protection of
the the children shouldn't that have
been a two-way street I mean shouldn't
the the rights of the children been or
the obligation of protecting the
children been considered from the
Davidians standpoint as well in terms of
well maybe we should drop this maybe we
should put the children's safety ahead
of our principles and go ahead and
surrender for the sake of the children
that's a very interesting questions a
very deep question I know it's one that
most Americans had on their minds during
the course the 51 days there's a couple
things that I think you need to
understand number one is when a tank
drives through your living room you tend
not to go out to those people that are
assaulting you when they start setting
up speaker systems you know you tend to
corporate as a group and say this is my
family if I think the more important
issue was that 18 people including men
and women and children did exit during
the 51 days when negotiations were going
good and keresh had one negotiator he
liked a lot and he kept asking for him
they pulled them off he's basically a
Christian guy he wanted to help he
really didn't crush had a great deal of
respect for him they pulled him off
during the course of 51 days he went
through I think it was 19 different FBI
negotiators you can't establish a
rapport you can't build a relationship
with someone that's going on so when
those 18 children you know men women and
children and several of them children
exited the building one of the things
that they did is they left with very
some of the parents stayed in some of
them didn't the kids had exited left
with very specific instructions we have
very specific dietary rules we didn't
want our kids out eating candy bars and
running around like kids of the world if
you will we believe that you know
according to our scriptures or certain
way these kids should be raised and
that's how they were raised you know and
they were all incredible children very
bright they helped each other you know
they could sit still you know I mean
they didn't run around and just wreak
havoc it's the point I want to make here
is that the FBI sent us in a videotape
and in the videotape they had the kids
he drinking soda pop eating candy bars
watching movies and maybe the mothers
wouldn't have this the mothers that
remained inside and the father men
inside were very upset about this
videotape and they called the FBI and
through the through the only one phone
line that we had and they said you guys
are going expressly against the rules
that we set out when we sent our
children on I don't want my kids raised
that way what are you doing why are you
doing this that's number one number two
I spoke to a woman her name was Julie
Martinez who became a very very close
friend of mine and Julie had several
children that died in there she had five
kids that died and she died as well and
Julie came to me one night during the
siege in tears I said what is wrong she
was I just got off the phone with the
FBI and they made it sound like if I
were to leave here and I don't know what
words the FBI used with her but I know
her reaction I know she was in tears and
she said they made it sound like if I
were to leave this building I would
never see my kids again they made me
feel so cheap and degrading and dirty
from even being there
David and the people in the midst of the
siege so you got parents that have a
that that believe they're never gonna
see their kids again you know and maybe
it is a selfish thing but when it comes
down to a mother and a child that's
that's a very strong dynamic in here
that's a lot of the reasons why people
stayed in and incidentally the kids were
placed under what they're placed in the
only area we had left to go
was it mostly kids were at the back of
the building and in the concrete
structure they were placed under wet
blankets now I've had federal
authorities say well they were placed
under the wet blankets you know to make
it look like you guys weren't committing
suicide I think that's the most
ridiculous thing I've ever heard in my
life they had no place to go
the back on April 19th was cut off the
media wasn't allowed back there for some
mysterious reason according to the
infrared videotape that son Waco the
rules of engagements and I cite this in
my book several gunshots were going off
at the back of the building the other
tanks now people want to ignore this you
know people want to say that I'm crazy
and I'm some kind of conspiratorial nut
for saying this I've seen the video you
can go rented at Blockbuster we have two
explosions the back of the building six
minutes before the fire begins we also
have several rounds of fully automatic
weapons according to Allard edward
Allard I believe his name is he was the
one that he was one of the gentlemen
that holds patents on the infrared video
technology says this is absolutely fully
automatic weapons fire nothing in nature
makes this thermal signature and you can
see these little flashes going off to
different areas and the most amazing
thing to me is as the fires building you
see the flashes back up you see the
flashes go from from the forth front
closer to the building and start backing
up as the fire is increasing I wish I
were making it up but I'm not it's it's
there yes sir
I have a question and that is that it
seems to me that every action that the
FBI took was directed at the children in
other words when they introduced CS into
your Mount Carmel and and this was
discussed in the joint congressional
hearings they targeted the children they
targeted the children with the idea that
the their mothers would try to save them
and rush out they also knew that every
adult had a gas mask but gas masks are
not made for children because they don't
work the lungs are not strong enough
another area of targeting the children I
think was the so called psychological
ops program where they showed the bright
lights and the loud music and the other
unusual sends now they claimed that
David Koresh was brutalizing in fact
beating quote beating the children is
what Janet Reno told us she was eating
babies was the eating babies and I think
all of us can understand that if someone
is is susceptible to to violence then
under stress he's likely to gain in more
violence
so these psychological operations again
would target the babies and make them be
beaten more by mr. Koresh so do you
think that the FBI had any concern for
the children as they claimed the head
not according to the actions and you
know that's such a great point I'm so
glad that you brought that up during the
course of the 51 days playing this music
I mean you know I'm a pretty peaceful
person and there was one time during the
siege where it was annoying me annoying
me to the point is when you're tired you
put in earplugs you can sleep you know
through just about anything I mean it's
amazing how the human spirit can adapt
you know we're very adaptable
kids aren't so well kids are adaptable
but it will definitely affect children
more so than it would adults one of the
things that just is absolutely shocking
to me is the fact that they would use
these SCI comps on the kids but more
importantly is people have to understand
about the CS gas they use it the tear
gas that they chose to use
internationally and I've done a little
research on the subject internationally
who cannot use CS gas in wartime and is
banned however there's no law stating we
can't use it against American citizens
according to the Dow Chemical report on
CS gas it says that CS gas is a riot
control agents that is only to be used
outdoors in an outdoor riot control
situation never to be used indoors
especially it says amongst women and
children especially children whose
respiratory tracts are not fully
developed it could kill them failure
analysis whose a scientific organization
they did a report on the CS gas in the
form the several the that throughout the
course of the six hours of April 19th
how much gas they put in there in some
areas of the building they put in CS gas
it was four times the amount needed to
detour a trained soldier let alone what
that will do to a little kid a little
baby well I don't want to lose my next
point
this CS gas is to me was one of the most
barbaric things you could ever
experience I mean I can't believe that
they could use that and Joyce Parks who
was the individual who was in charge of
the state investigation against Koresh
and the child abuse issues had come out
to the property was his Sheriff's
Department and crush's question you jack
car while the sheriff of Waco we had
worked with law enforcement in the past
we invited the ATF I we didn't go
looking for them they made it sound like
we weren't looking for them like we had
some plan she said in an interview that
she urged the FBI not to do the CS gas
plan to wait a mountain 7/7 Anna Script
urged them and said well basically you
know I should I get my team ready and
they said now don't worry about it one
time don't worry about it you know what
were they planning one time nerd during
the negotiation they were asking how
many fire extinguishers we had in there
and did a report said all we have two
fire extinguishers in the building and
the FBI negotiator said well it's about
time you buy some fire insurance oh yeah
this might go figure
and you which brings me up to my next
point real quick another interesting
terrible tragedy that occurred occurred
a few months before our attack and that
of course is Randy Weaver and what
happened to his family in the middle of
Idaho in the middle of a side of a
mountain and without getting too
detailed I just want you to know the
mentality of these people and this is
what happened absolutely is it came out
in the in the trials for his his case
his son sandy
Sammy thank you was shot his dog started
barking they went down a marshal shot
the dog
Sammy shot at the marshal he ran back
and one of the marshals shot and killed
him the next day Randy Weaver put his
his dead son in the shed next to the
house and was walking was walking to the
main building and FBI sniper lon T who
are you Qi who was one of the only
people that has been left on the law so
we have a civil case against the
government everyone's all the people
were going after has been thrown off
except LAN T or you would she was a who
was the FBI sniper that was there that
day lon T or you Chi gets Vicki Weaver
and his sights no he starts opening up
on on on Kevin Harrison and Randy as
they're running into the house they got
that Vicki's got the door open she got
her baby in her arms and lunch he were
you Chi from 200 yards away with a
high-powered scope shoots her in the
face she falls forward with the baby in
her arms
now the trials during that particular
case it was asked mister Horiuchi didn't
you know from 200 yards away that this
woman had a baby in her in her in her
arms and he said no I thought it was a
firearm so I shot her now I've talked to
snipers that you know I've talked to
people who have been in the military
anyone here in the military was in the
military 200 yards away do you know what
you're shooting with a high-powered
scope that's all I want to know yes you
do this gentleman's waving his head yes
is several people from all over this
country that have spoke to have told me
the same thing he knew what he was
shooting but here's the key
day they had speaker systems set up in
that little debacle as well the next day
the the negotiators are someone from the
FBI got on the horn they said Randy
what's Vicky gonna make you for
breakfast this morning
I mean that that's unfathomable to me to
me that our federal authorities are
servants people that under the
Constitution of taking an oath to serve
the American public could do that to
anybody I don't care if he's a fascist
or a racist it's certain rights and this
guy isn't was never on trial I don't
want to get too far off I just want you
to realize it this kind of stuff
happened to us all the time during the
course of the 51 days you know I mean
the FBI agents would moon us you know
the women would be looking out of the
out of the windows and they be mooning
us and sticking their middle finger up
at us yeah this is the federal
government yes sir
before the siege before all the troubles
in the siege began describe a typical
day what did you do
were you happy there what were some of
the do's and dont's rules and
regulations before all the before all
the troubles began great question um in
my book a place called Waco I spent a
lot of time on these issues because
humanly you go through a lot of mixed
emotions you know you go a lot of the
things like questions a lot of the
things that were going on in there but
basically I understood one thing you
know I mean some of the stuff that
occurred there was a part of the plan
and I accepted it generally we would
play music or build we spent most of our
days building and beautifying the
property you know we didn't do that cuz
we were planning on committing a mass
suicide
you know we had put in the tracks we had
put in we were building up the house we
had built the pool for ourselves and
most of the times were spent working and
in the evenings we would study had three
square meals and some of the women would
prepare and we'd all come and eat
together and the studies usually
occurred in the evening that was your
basic life I mean there were periods of
time where we would watch movies
everything was on occasion there were
times when everyone would have ice cream
there was times and we would get burgers
you know and everyone the community had
a burger but basically people stayed
there people were what I think believed
David Koresh was inspired I believe they
were crush was inspired and basically we
spent our lives
this truth because according to the
truth and I do get into this very deeply
in the book according to the truth this
group was going to be targeted and was
going to be attacked
you know we had prepared for that at the
same time Koresh did everything humanly
to try to avoid the situation he also
believed there was another plan and that
that plan could go forward with music
and he could reach the world that way so
it's kind of confusing it's dualistic
and that was one of the hard things in
writing the book it took me several
years to even conceive of writing this
book because I thought it was such a
complicated subject I thought there was
no way I could explain my experience I
still think to this day there's aspects
of the truth that I don't even get into
I do not come I did not want to get into
David's scripture in this book he said I
don't believe that that's my role or
that I'm aspired to do that so I'm
trying to tell the story from my
experience without getting to the hard
core belief of why we were there and
that's what's very difficult for me in
writing this book and you know I think
it's something that can be researched
there are some of the Davidians that
have written down their version of the
seven seals and anyone that's interested
can look that up on websites I didn't I
couldn't quote the site right now but I
didn't feel it was my role but what I
did feel was that you know we were out
there studying we were out there living
and we bothered no one for 60 years if
you really wanted to everyone's always
free to leave that's part of your free
moral agency as a person I mean
generally the group did things together
and the group didn't really depart from
that considering that we were one body
according to several scriptures if one
person does something or does something
that's against the basic rules of the
community affects the entire community
and so living under that structure yes
it was a rigid a rigorous structure yes
it was a very monastic lifestyle but at
the same time it's a lifestyle that
everyone chose to live and I could have
left at any time but consciously in my
head I did not feel that I would be
doing the right thing I don't think that
I could have been left David to do my
own thing in life and felt that I could
look myself in the mirror and I've read
several books on on psychology and
social proof and
and combating mind control and ice all
kinds of different literature that's out
there you know I think that for me I
just made the decisions I had to make in
life that this was I was put here for a
reason to go through this experience for
a reason the question was do I think I
still be there for the troubles haven't
started I can't I don't know I think I
might but I also think maybe twenty
years down the road I don't know if I
could have curbed my humanity that much
you know I'm not a saint you know I'm a
sinner like the rest of us I think there
were people there that were close to
saintliness I I can't ask that question
it's something that was an experience
that I took day by day yes sir um Alex
Jones a local radio talk show host has
been really keeping this issue alive too
over the long before this latest
revelations have been coming out he's
leading an effort right now to rebuild
the church on the property up there do
you have anything to do with that or are
you planning on going back and who owns
that property now great question I'm
glad you brought that up someone that
was gonna get into but the rebuilding of
the church on the ground where all this
people died and all these atrocities
took place I think it's a beautiful
thing and the fact that so many Texans
do to Alex Jones and then do to people
that do care and that do you know that
they were lied to and do one another
truth have come forward and not only
donated their materials and and and and
and money to make this project happen
but they've donated their time they've
come out on Sundays and they've helped
to rebuild this church so we can have a
standing Monument a sanctuary out there
not only for the people that study but
as a symbol a symbol that the human
spirit will endure and we are adaptable
and as long as you hold on to your
purpose in life or your site you don't
lose touch with that with what you
consider to be God what you consider to
be right for you that you can overcome
you know those people didn't die in vain
and I think it's just so amazing to me
especially in Texas here because I mean
how much demonization was there here in
this state during the whole thing I mean
I came out of there
and I remember standing from the grand
jury and I felt mentally raped the last
thing I wanted to withstand before 18
people that lived in Waco that looked at
me like I was the biggest freak they
ever saw in their life and didn't
believe a word I said that was the most
uncomfortable situation I've ever been
CS gassed and that was a little more
uncomfortable in the CS gas frankly so
it's incredible that people have come in
for coming forward and every Sunday they
go out there and build it should be done
the next couple months
and if anyone that would like
information on the building of the
structure they can go to WWE info
wars.com to get that information and
also W W rebuild the church comm and
that's that's one word and I just really
appreciate everything there everyone's
done one of the goals I have for my
website which is a place called Waco
comm is to put the CS gas report and put
all this information there the warrants
on there so people can read from
themselves but also and I just I should
have done this years ago and frankly I
was not proactive before it took me a
lot of time to go through everything
that I had to go through in this and
then finally come out on the point where
I could say okay let's take him on you
know it's gone far enough my friends are
in jail I could be in jail not that I
did anything wrong but I could be in
jail just for political reasons and I
want someone out there fighting for me
so what I want to do is start a petition
to get the guys out of jail I mean come
on people you know we can let terrorists
go and free them for political reasons
but seven innocent people that are in
jail on the jury you know I'm sorry mr.
establishment mr. Clinton mr. FBI you
whoever wants to criticize me on this
one the jury said if they had seen all
the evidence that the judge had
suppressed from them everyone would be
released everyone that you're the head
jury forewoman wants a retrial
you know people like Edward Allard stone
want a retrial I mean it's time these
people do not deserve to be there the
wrong people are in jail and you know
what if these people have to go on
suffering and suffering and suffering
that what a terrible terrible state of
affairs were in here in this country
see on the right here's the way we were
listening and using the internet on this
for some time when it was very active
and over 200 messages were posted on the
board and some of the people were
pathetically trying to cling to the
beliefs that we had that this is a fair
and honest and nation of laws
it was unbelievable my conclusion was
that the intent from the outset was to
kill every one of you there is I've
heard nothing to dissuade me from that
there's a Los Angeles rabbi said that a
soul shall be judged not only by what it
says and does but by what it sees and
condones by silence and though much of
that has gone thank you for being here
would you have a question while you're
up do you think thank you for you cuz
it's beautiful you know that the ATF had
the plan of literally putting everyone
killing everyone
they certainly intended to kill the
children what you said about the dosage
of CS the children could not have
survived eight consecutive hours of
pumping gas into a closed building it's
not possible the children were dead from
that well what I think is in your
referring to the FBI I think that the
ATF when they when they staged their
raid and they had the helicopters firing
into the building and the agents coming
in firing I think that their goal was to
get crushed I mean I think that's why
they had the helicopters frankly and
when they targeted the area they
believed was his bedroom you know
because they didn't want that I mean
that's a great point
keresh jogged in front of his their
house every day for two weeks he was in
town all the time and the FBI when they
took over they said well crush was
isolated he never came out and all of a
sudden people in Waco in the community
said hey I saw him at Chelsea's club two
weeks ago you know I saw he was in my
store just the other day and he jogged
with about five or six of the guys I did
it on a couple of occasions when I
actually felt like I wanted to try to
get the shape
I got in front of their house - two
weeks right in front of their undercover
house every single day they could have
gotten not only David crash but a
hardcore group of the young men around
taking them right there they never
wanted to do it peacefully that's what
blows my mind I think they wanted this
dynamic entry I think that it's
something that we see all these cop
shows you know we see this this dynamic
entry this force we got to go in and get
these drug dealers that's the point I
wanted to make that's the point I wanted
to make real quick they got the
helicopters through the only way that
they could use helicopters against
American citizens is under a loop all
the DEA law where it states that if you
are manufacturing drugs all of a sudden
you can use military equipment against
the evil drug dealers and go in and get
him they said that we had a
methamphetamine lab in there and they
went to the governor and she okayed
governor Ann Richards ok the helicopters
to be used because they convinced her
and they convinced the authorities that
there was a methamphetamine lab David
Koresh got people off drugs
David Koresh didn't take aspirin during
the siege who wouldn't take aspirin he'd
never did drugs they knew that he never
did drugs but they wanted to get the
helicopters so why not lie let's lie you
know well not only lie to the American
public you know hey you know there
sheeple will just lie to them you know
that they're gonna follow along with
what we say but let's lie to the
authorities we lie to the judge will lie
to the governor well lad whoever we can
to bring about the end that we want and
that end is very proud its very arrogant
it's very what's the word I'm looking
for
it's very male violent you know and
that's not what I thought this country
was about growing up you know and I'll
be frank yeah I was raised with some of
the atrocities that were going on in
Chile and Nicaragua and Panama you know
anyone sees a Panama deception knows
that there was something more to what
was going on there but the fact that it
happened here on this soil it wasn't you
know the government going out into other
foreign lands and making this happen or
backing some rebel group that's going in
committing mass murders or backing
Indonesian to went and kill these two
Moors the the East Timor East people
that happened years ago years ago there
was a massacre not just happening now
happened several several years ago took
a man like Noam Chomsky to bring this
out to the
old it's just very it's very frightening
to me you know and now it's happening
here on a soil and unfortunately there's
a very large group of Americans that'll
sit there and they'll see it happen and
go like well you know those people are
probably bad that reserve and what
they're getting and they don't even
understand what the forefathers built
this constitution on did the children
have any schooling other than like the
Bible's yeah they had home schooling
there was actually a couple teachers
that lived there one with sherry Jewell
and she was a teacher and she she taught
the kids but was more impressively than
the homeschooling and some of them
didn't go to school for quite some time
and then they were taken out of school
about a year before everything happened
and pretty much was consistently
homeschooling what impressed me most
about these kids that that the older
kids would take care of the younger kids
and would actually read books to them so
the sharing in that community was
unbelievable the fact that like a you
know a 13 year old girl would sit there
and read all these little kids and you
know they would just share different
stories and stuff they it's like the
kids educated the other kids as well as
the adults that were in there so yes
there was absolutely excellent education
for the kids
ok ok this is my favorite part I could
go on all night
yeah the dynamic entry is a interesting
thing on the one hand be ATF wanted to
make a show type of entry but much more
importantly I think is who provides the
justification for everything that
happened to legal authority and the
provision of legal authority comes from
the office of US attorney a branch of
the Justice Department and it was the
assistant US attorney William Johnson
who participated in every aspect every
aspect of the event in Waco from
beginning to the prosecution and he is
the man who demanded he demanded of the
be ATF that the entry be one such that
mr. Koresh could not get rid of any of
the end of the evidence he said I won't
prosecute it unless you do an entry that
doesn't give him a chance
that if you give him a chance to dispose
the evidence I will not prosecute so he
gave the V ATF the authority in my
opinion to to do their so-called dynamic
entry he was behind it and then of
course he was the one involved in that
affidavit he helped prepare it with all
its errors and in misstatements he gave
it to judge green a former prosecutor
himself and said here here it is the
judge is supposed to look at it as a
neutral party instead he rubber stamped
it and Johnston was involved in every
aspect of it in my opinion if there's
one single person most responsible for
the whole incident it's William Johnston
one point I want to make to that and
then we do got a close is also I it's
pretty amazing to see the turnaround
that Johnston has done and you have to
understand that when Mike McNulty
started to go into the evidence Locker
which brought this whole
thing back into the press again when he
started to do that he started to turn a
lot of people around likely Hancock of
the Dallas Morning News who broke this
now Lee Hancock was never ever fair
favorable to us of the Davidians she
wrote some of the most incredible pieces
of that just disgusted me while this is
happening and now she turned around
william johnson wrote a letter to it to
Attorney General Janet Reno and said
there's a lot you don't know that we
have found out that I think the FBI and
people have are hiding from you and
covering from you that you need to be
aware about they pull them off he's no
longer working anymore because they say
that it would they want to use him for a
witness so they can't have him in that
capacity so he's been pulled off of his
official duties basically lost his job
if you will because he made this aware
to Janet Reno I mean it's very strange
to me so it's like the higher-ups I mean
people that were responsible for getting
Koresh have done a lot of them have done
and a complete turnaround and it's just
amazing to see people in power and
people in authority people with prestige
coming forward and doing this turn
around I mean it just shows how powerful
that this media structure is and that
this government is in in deceit and in
taking you away from what is really
going on and so on the one hand yeah I
think your point is valid but I think
that at this point I think mr. Johnson
is doing the right thing and I hope that
more people do with the right thing I
mean if there's one thing I can say I'll
and with this my view of the
Constitution my view of my studies of
George Washington Jefferson Lincoln and
the document inspired document we live
by called the Constitution is that if
you take a no I don't care if you're a
traffic cop are you the President of the
United States of America my belief is if
you raise your hand and you put your
other hand on the Bible and you take an
oath to serve the American public that's
what you are your servant if you take an
oath to serve the American public then
you should be held by that oath and I
think if you violate that oath then I
think that the punishment should be
severe more severe than
an average citizen who hasn't taken any
oath that that does a crime they go to
jail right well if we don't hold our
official authorities responsible then
we're gonna have problems that we've
seen like in Oklahoma there are people
that within a nation of 250 million
people
you got some fringes out there you got
some people that don't understand what's
going on some people that can't handle
their anger and they do insane things
and if the government does not be
truthful with us if they do not hold the
people that are responsible for lying to
us and responsible for shooting us and
responsible for for deceiving us if
those people are not held responsible
then there will be more people that
aren't so level-headed that'll do
terrible terrible acts and the problem
is is the government the media will
blame it on constitutionalists they'll
blame it on us radicals like David
Thibodeau is out there speaking against
the government I love this nation you
know I think we've got the best form of
government on the face of the earth but
I know that we can make it better you
know there should be reason before
there's any active force and if there
isn't then then why am I here why are we
here well you know what why don't we
still deceive ourselves and think we're
living by these principles
that's all I just want justice you know
I'm not out for revenge I want just as
there are people that are walking around
that are guilty of lying of killing of
shooting of gassing and they're people
that are in jail that are innocent and
until the paradigm shifts then we're
gonna have problems and I don't want my
nation to have problems anymore
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen I have books
available right over here at this table
for sale if you would like to get one
signed and if you would would please
take a number we are gonna call number
groups for the books
to be signed thank you very much sir
Mike him with being purified by the FBI
- have you ever heard of Bernie Romero
no he could be on that he could get Hugh
stuff from Oklahoma dude I gave a friend
of your side lately and they kidnap
night following this discussion of a
place called way co-author David
Thibodeau signed copies of his book
oh you know good nicely wouldn't you
come out fire mother's the day this
first started or that when I actually
started or earlier that they know that
yeah turn the fire during their life
basically I thought I was gonna be shot
if I left so I preferred to be shot that
burnt death was kind of my recently at
the time you got I came out of the side
of the cameras can see him easily right
it's an amazing thing
first let me to make this out to it's
your ROI us an ally for five years and I
just is such a breath of fresh air aside
the weight of the world off my shoulders
being here it's the people it's a great
town especially a friend music I'm
surprised I know I didn't think I could
live in Texas again after my experience
it's great I really like it
[Music]
[Music]
someone gave that to me well working
yeah this is the car that's the part
that make sure this is the card that
Steve Schneider and David Kirsch gave to
me that very first day is this very card
someone gave it to me at work the fame
Messiah productions card with the
religious scripture on the back
Cyrus productions Messiah Cyrus
productions Rihanna it's real it's the
real deal right there cool all right
thank you
congratulations for surviving and then
producing the parking traffic yeah
what's your name sir comrade Schlenker C
Co n ra d I'm Schneider SCH and he s th
enemy yeah Katie our warrants this has
been a bizarre because there in general
yeah I forget to mention that in Texas
you're 68 million firearms for 16
million people and most people go the
gun issue they flip out they don't
realize that this is it's a different
mentality I mean Texas is that's why
they wanted to do that a very special
place 15,000 registered tax
- there was no as a patient there was so
horrible nobody alive in the state
anymore
that's what Clinton and his folks wanted
to do put the big show on here to
intimidate everybody else come in there
for the big show thank you very much
their hometown yeah I'm so sorry for
what you had to go through especially
sorry that just you ever was it it
I told not people a long time ago said
someday you're gonna get the real story
you may not get it now from all the lies
but someday you will know or you know
what happened and I think it's gonna
happen hopefully he's have enough much
is it more masculine ever has before
right you know it's just people
sometimes need a lot of time to rethink
things you know that's the problem with
the power of the press and power utter
an agenda returns the agenda is amazing
it was right in scripturally it says
they're there their words are like the
words you're very soft but they're they
don't realize that they're like razors
not trucks towards the Ettore sharpen
the sterner they got me sayin compound
sometimes confident yeah I'm confident
cause it's insane
it is you know Thomas